Muslim country but even in these is
country this these Islamic countries
that are throwing acid in the face I
genuinely think is something to do it's
definitely a hate crime
I've got III believe it's something to
do with Islamophobia baby I don't know
if people are trying to tell me a that
but I mean we're innocent people we
didn't deserve that
it was my cousin's 21st birthday
squirted this layer liquid over us which
I thought it was water until my cousin
side to scream she I was watching her
burning next thing you know I'm burning
out of panic I've stripped naked
I've stripped her as much as I could I'm
dragging her she's screaming and crying
I'm screaming I'm kicking on people's
doors banging on doors crying screaming
she's screaming people are coming out
I'm telling them listen we've just been
attacked with acid yeah obviously I knew
by that time I mean that this gotta be
acid their foreign bacchus all or over
her
they're throwing buckets of water over
me somebody came up with a hose pipe yet
people are coming out if I and so now
when I went to the hospital that they
they had to jet wash me with water to
get that acid off I was it was
excruciating pain I was I was screaming
like a baby he was in new general at the
time she wouldn't she didn't want to
leave me because she's from Manchester
she's petrified so they brought both of
us here
I've never seen describe my life I don't
have any problems with anybody my
cousin's 21
she's the business student but I mean
why would anyone do that was and I
honestly feel that if this was a white
person that got attacked by an Asian
person he'd be caught within 24 hours
it'd be all over the news
there'd be a national manhunt I've been
left here
I must cousins been left here to just
shrivel up and wait
and all of the sins is Tang juris lies
thank you for everybody out there not
just Muslims everybody is like we have
this probably not the bridge
Westminister bridge that is promises
report most and now this is acid attacks
paranoid I mean me and my cousin Jamie I
have attended if exactly what he knows
whatever I mean what this guy tried to
kill us
I'm lucky I'm alive Muslim country but
even in these country this these Islamic
countries that are throwing acid in the
face she suffered third-degree burns
when her ex-boyfriend hired another man
to throw acid in her face these people
that practice the Islamic religion boys
he would normally and motion those are
the words David Phillips will get onto
him in just a moment these Islamic
countries pay the attack happened in
daylight in downtown Vancouver
Washington they bring up acid in the
face Muslim country but even in these
countries these Islamic countries
[Applause]
Christy sim slipped into a coma two
months later she awakened and this is
what she looked like against these
radical fundamentalist people that are
throwing acid in the face a woman
approached her and said hey pretty girl
and she turned around and she asked if
she wanted something to drink and my
daughter said no the attacker splattered
acid directly into Bethany's face you
say you'd known her for 10 years
yeah 11 12 yeah 21 year old only may
frumpy Phnom Penh Cambodia was not
having it when her fiance 23 year old
lynx-o Giada broke up with her she
decided it would be a good idea to try
and pour acid on him while riding on the
back
motorcycle these things are horrible
right that if Islam was implemented that
the the Sharia or the law and you did
something like this dosa acid or you do
you bring harm to a human human being
like this you know in this way I mean
what would happen yeah I mean this is
really it's it's taking advantage of
people's ignorance of exactly
most people don't know a thing about
Islam and they're like okay you know let
me inform you what Islam is instead of
telling them all Muslims believe in one
God and they play they pray five times a
day and they give charity and they fast
in the month of Ramadan let me just
teach you these things which are some
cultural practice that I found somewhere
and let me attribute them to Islam
somehow so that you become afraid of
Islam you know that's where Islamophobia
comes from yeah irrational false fear of
Islam